I want to mention something one of the
last roles before you got your own show
congratulations thank you no but before
you play about your own show you were in
Sons of Anarchy
is that right I was and you were cast as
Latin woman number one yes that way yeah
and that's the last role you had before
you got your own so that's a massive
leap I didn't even get a name they don't
describe to me Latin woman number one it
was that experience well you know I was
I think it was a drug mule and I don't
mean a brag and the description was like
they told me she had to be dirty like
she had a hard life and bla bla so the
day we shot I had told my boyfriend at
the time like I'm not gonna do my hair
or makeup I want to see how they dirty
me up and then I went to the set and
they sent me to her makeup and they're
like oh you're perfect like a drug mule
every day of my life
I'm in the wrong business that's amazing
what's it what's it like to have your
own sitcom I mean this is this is an
amazing experience I would imagine I I
mean how do you even express it like how
do how do you describe it like do you
know what it's like to have a show named
after you not my real name
you know it's funny because usually when
I ask someone that they don't have a
show named after you do it's it's like
it's like shooting a really high high
high budget YouTube video well it's
funny because so many people and then
probably you too could just make lots of
videos on YouTube so it used to be you
were either on television or you
couldn't express your comedy at all
right and now you have to do you to now
they expect you to do everything now if
you want to do if you want to stand up
you have to have you have to keep up
your Twitter your myspace still MySpace
I'll sign up you know there's your
Twitter Facebook vine Instagram you got
to have your own YouTube channel you got
to do a web series you got fanfiction
you know like for Conan which I do he
walked into the road coppertop add me a
ginger yeah what what and now Roseanne
Barr is on your show yes that's so
exciting
yeah to get Roseanne Barr I actually got
Roseanne Barr by Craig who does my hair
he does Roseanne's hair too oh yeah
you've heard of him the guy is like I'm
named Craig
why does he shooting guns I yeah we
tried to guns away we may get testy I
get their gun um he does rose hands hair
and he told her that I had been doing
the rounds and I always talked about how
much I loved her
so he introduced us and I asked her to
be on my show because I love Roseanne
Roseanne was a game changer for me I
made changed a game for a lot of women
she was a woman was unapologetically
herself I grew up in a border town in
South Texas and I related to her she was
exactly like she was exactly like me
so when she said yes I was thrilled then
we have her for two episodes and we get
a second season she'll come back for
more your hair dress your hair stylist
yes set this whole thing up yeah he
actually is the one that booked me on
this show
you